JP: Well welcome, everyone.
First of all, thank you
very much for waiting
in the hot sun outside in line
to come to our presentation.
My name is JP.
PETER: And I'm Peter, and we're
here from the Google Developer
training team.
JP: And we're excited to present
our first Google certification:
Associate Android Developer,
a performance-based exam
where you'll write real
apps to show your skill.
PETER: So the Google
Developer Training Team
is part of the Developer
Relations Team at Google.
And in this team,
our mission, really,
is to educate and
inspire developers.
And we'd like to
do that at scale.
So what we'd like to
do is help developers
like yourself teach the best
practices, the design patterns,
the tips and tricks
that you need
to know to build high
quality apps in the most
efficient way possible.
Now, JP and I and other
members of the training team
that are also here today, we've
been in this training world
for awhile.
And one of the things about
developer certifications
is whether you
should do it or not.
And it's kind of
a tricky balance.
Many certification
programs kind of
miss the mark of what they're
intending to try to do.
And so at the same time, we
felt that the certification
could really set the bar
for helping people achieve
some of their goals--
career wise, job wise--
and really accomplish
what they want to do.
And that's what we're trying to
set up with this program here
today that we're
really excited about.
JP: What we want to
do today is give you
a short view of the
program, introduce you
to Associate Android Developer
and really show you how to get
started.
We want to keep this
short and sweet.
We want to give you lots of
time for questions and answers,
and give you lots
of time so you can
get a good seat for
the concert too.
So imagine a developer.
She has this amazing app, and
she wants to change the world.
Now, if you're already
an entrepreneur
or an independent app developer,
you can do this today.
And we even have
training to help you.
However, there's
other situations,
situations where
it's not quite so
easy to go from zero to
hero, where developers
around the world look for
and need resources to help
them accomplish their dreams.
So one of these
situations, which
is familiar to probably many
of us, is getting a job.
Maybe you or someone
you know is looking
for a job as an app developer.
Maybe it's a first job, or maybe
it's a new job or a new career.
You have ideas.
You have skills.
You have a network.
But maybe you can't quite
connect to employers
to land that job.
There's really a gap
between skilled developers
and those jobs that will let
them fulfill their dreams.
Now, as Peter and I started
to look at this gap,
and other members
on the training team
looked at this gap, we
discovered it was really,
I'd say, way larger
than we thought.
We saw it in
developer education.
We saw it in the job market.
We saw it where skills that
employers were looking for
and how people were
training to get those jobs.
And really, two questions arose.
The first question,
for employers,
how do you show that
somebody is qualified?
How do you know that somebody
can perform the tasks that
are required of them?
The second one, for
individuals, how
do you stand out for job
interviews and get recognized,
whether it's for a new
job or a promotion?
PETER: Separately, a
lot of industry studies
came out that showed that we
had a significant disadvantage
here.
For example, this report
from Vision Mobile
really pointed that out.
And we realized the lack of
this objective industry standard
was really holding us
back, and specifically
in different countries
around the world.
Now, we started thinking
about this quite deeply.
And I have to say,
this is something
that kept us up at night.
We really wanted to
solve that for Google.
Now, generally with the rise of
these alternative credentialing
methods, like the
ones you're probably
familiar with with Udacity
and General Assembly,
we realized that there
was a real appetite
for learning app development
that would directly
lead to jobs.
And so over the last few
years, we've done quite a bit
to close this gap.
And perhaps a lot
of you are already
familiar with some
of our training.
But I'll go into a little
more detail on that as well.
So for example, with Udacity,
our online training partner,
we built 35 MOOC
training courses
providing end to end paths
for Android development, web
development, and tech
entrepreneurship.
We also built other courses
around machine learning
and cloud computing and so on.
Now over the last few years,
the people enrolling in this
have really
dramatically increased,
and it's still picking
up a lot of steam.
For example, we now have
1 and 1/4 million people
enrolled in our Google
courses on Udacity.
And we have about 2,500 people
enrolling in these courses
every single day, right now.
So it's been a really
good platform for us
to get the message out,
to educate developers,
which is our original mission.
Now, we also realize
that not everyone
learns with the same--
online and self-paced.
And so we worked together
with General Assembly
to build a complete 12 week
Android immersive, sort
of a full time in-person course
where you go on-site and spent
12 weeks really
dedicated to that,
whereas most of the online
learning is self-paced.
And we just had our first
people graduate from that.
The first cohort in New
York, about 25 people,
and the next one is
graduating very soon here
in San Francisco.
And there is going to be opening
up about 12 order locations
globally.
So I wanted to take just a
quick step back about what we've
done, specifically to Android.
Two years ago at I/O, we
released the first Android
fundamentals or Developing
Android Apps training
course with Udacity.
And that's sort of our
flagship Android course.
We have almost 300,000 people
enrolled in that course.
I think it's 288,000
at last count.
This is a course
that's developed
by Reto Meier, Katherine Kuan,
who's here in the audience,
and Dan Galpin.
So a really great course.
But at that time, we
were still building
in a very ad hoc manner.
So we were building one
course on the HTML5 games,
another one on mobile
web development,
and another one on
Android fundamentals.
But what we were lacking
was that well-lit path
for developers through
an entire curriculum that
would lead directly to jobs.
And so we decided to
start building that.
And last year at I/O
[INAUDIBLE] announced
that we launched the
Android Nanodegree.
And later in the year, we
launched that in September,
or relaunched that
effectively, in India
with local pricing,
1,000 scholarships,
and local e-commerce
options for Indian students
to take that as well.
Of course, they could have
taken that by itself already.
Now late last year, we started
seeing the first graduates
from these Nanodegrees.
It takes generally
about six to 12 months
for people to complete.
We hosted a career
summit in Mountain View
for about the 50 top students.
And what we're seeing there is
that people are getting jobs.
For example, in India, we
have 16 Nanodegree students.
And keep in mind that this
is still kind of early days
because it takes
six to 12 months,
and it's only been 12 months.
And out of these six
students, four of them
were hired without even as much
as an interview at Flipkart.
So pretty amazing stories.
Some of these graduates have
also been hired at Google.
So a pretty high level
of mastery, and just
a great outcome.
We also launched last year the
Android for Beginners course.
This is a fantastic course.
All you need for that is
a phone, a computer where
you can install Android Studio,
and an Internet connection.
You could take that
course and really
take you from zero
programing experience
all the way to actually having
apps running on your machine.
That's Katherine
Kuan and [INAUDIBLE],
who are here in the
audience today, somewhere.
Raise your hand.
There.
All right, thank you.
So we launched that
as well last year.
So then fast forward
to this year.
We realized there
were still a big gap.
Generally we say that
for Android fundamentals
and the Android Nanodegree,
you need about two years
of programming experience.
Android for Beginners takes
you part of the way there,
but it's not quite complete.
And so we've been working
really hard-- in fact,
Katherine and
[INAUDIBLE] have been
working really
hard-- on bridging
that gap in intermediate
Android development skills.
And so stay tuned for some
really exciting announcements
in that space because we're
building out, effectively,
an entire end to end path
for developers on Android
so that we no longer
have to tell people,
if you want to take
the Android Nanodegree,
go off and go to these
16 different places
to learn the prerequisites.
So we'll have an end to
end, zero to hero path
for all of that.
So in summary, we've
come a long way
to closing that gap
that JP described.
When we're trying to accelerate
that gap even further.
And so today, we're
taking one step closer
to supercharging how employers
and employees can effectively
work together in the
most efficient way.
JP: Today we're excited to
announce Google Developer
Certification, a new program
to help close the gap
for employers and job seekers,
to help set common standards,
and to help
developers worldwide.
Now, we're very excited
about this program.
We think that it's going to
help developers stand out,
be recognized, get a job, help
build higher quality apps.
And I'm going to tell you about
the details, what it contains,
and how you can benefit.
Now, if you're an
individual, if you've
got a great idea, if
you're looking for a job,
or maybe you represent
a company or an agency
looking for talent, we think
we've got something for you.
PETER: Now, I want to talk
a little bit about how this
is not, let's say, an ordinary
developer certification,
or expel a few
myths that you might
think about when you think
of developer certification.
So one of the big
things here is that it's
based on job task
analysis, and JP
will tell you more about
that in a little bit.
The big difference with,
let's say, a typical exam
is that this is a
performance-based exam.
We're trying to take
certification into 2016,
do it in a bit of a Googley way.
And basically, you'll need to
build apps and show your skills
to pass these exams.
It's very performance-based.
So it's not a 200 question,
trick question, multiple choice
exam.
It's not really
a knowledge test.
It's really testing
actual app development.
JP: So we've thought about this.
And I think, as Peter
was alluding to,
we thought about the
traditional concept
of technical certification
for developers.
Now, in other industries, there
may be performance-based exams
that work well.
But specifically,
when we're looking
at technical certification
for app developers,
it was something that we
really need to think about.
So we thought first we need
to make it job-focused,
as Peter alluded to.
When we say job-focused, we
mean that every certification
that we develop
is actually mapped
to a job that's in the
industry, as determined
and vetted by a
job task analysis.
Peter also mentioned
performance-based exams.
So we take an exam
that we will develop.
Let's just take one.
In that, you'll be
asked to build, extend,
add functionality
to an existing app,
or determine and correct
defects in the code.
So we feel like this is similar
to the task the developer would
do in the real world, for
an entry level developer.
And as opposed to a
knowledge-based exam,
it's going to evaluate the
ability to perform tasks.
Can you do the task
required in the job?
Not recall facts or concepts.
Probably one of the
things that's probably
most important for this
program is how we're
going to be using rubrics.
Now typically, rubrics,
you just kind of say,
OK I have to know these things,
and if I know these things,
I'll do well.
Well, there is some
aspect of that, of course,
for us and with grading.
The rubrics will be
transparent, published,
you'll have them as soon
as you sign up for an exam.
You'll know what you need to
do in order to pass that exam.
But it also would
reduce ambiguity.
It's going to make it
very clear, very empirical
and objective how you will
earn the certification.
So if you're prepared,
if you can build an app,
and you know these rubrics,
you should be in good shape
to pass and earn one of
these certifications.
We like to say there's
no tricks, no guile, just
measurable performance.
PETER: So JP showed
you a little bit
about our overall
certification program.
And we're really
excited about that.
And today, we're
launching the first
in the series, Associate
Android Developer.
Now, this certification
maps to what
you would need to know as an
entry level Android developer.
Now, the exams for this,
they will open up in July.
And so today, it's all
about getting prepared.
Now, a lot of you,
in this audience,
you're probably
Android developers,
and you may already be
ready to pass this exam.
But if you're not, and
you need to brush up
on some of these skills, we
have a great training page.
You can find out all about
our certification and training
offerings that we have
to help you get ready.
So you can find our
new certification page
that we just launched
earlier today that
has more details on it.
You can find there
what these rubrics
are that we talked about,
what the program is all about.
And today, you can sign up,
literally just put your email
in, so we can notify you as
soon as the exams open up.
So the key takeaway here is
you can start your journey
toward certification.
Now, how do you prepare?
So coming back to that
landscape of Android
training that we developed
over the last few years.
Really what this is about is
more on the advanced side--
on the intermediate to
advanced side-- which
is based on, if we
zoom into, let's say,
that advanced
Udacity nanodegree.
Then you can take
Android fundamentals,
which is really the course
to dive into that maps
to the task analysis.
Can we get the next slide?
Great.
So Android fundamentals
maps closest to the job task
analysis that we performed.
And so by taking
that course, you
can really get ready
to get the exam.
Now, taking that
course also means
you have to do all the
practical parts of that.
Right?
It's not just
watching the video,
but it's actually really
getting your hands dirty,
building the projects
that come with that
and really mastering
that material.
So that's, in essence, what I
think the best place to start
with to get started today.
JP: So that's great.
Thank you, Peter.
That's how you go about
preparing for this exam.
And you can do that,
again, starting today.
So what about July?
Let's fast forward a little bit.
When July comes, what
you'll do is you'll
complete your sign-up process.
You'll be presented
with some projects.
Basically, the
projects will represent
what you need to know in
order to pass the exam
and then earn the certification.
When you get these
projects, you'll
work on them
independently, submit them.
They'll be graded, and ding!
You'll be certified.
Then you can take your
mark, show recruiters, show
employers, show your friends.
I don't know, hand it in front
of your dog and let him see it.
Something like that.
Show your mark,
so you can proudly
show everyone what
you've earned.
And not only that, we
looked at grading too.
Sometimes in certifications,
it becomes just something
earned to just get through.
We really wanted this to
be part of your learning
path towards mastery as well.
So when we think about
grading for this,
it's not pass or fail.
It's really you get
three chances to pass.
You can retake the exam.
And there's a combination of
machine and human grading.
So with the human
grading, Android experts
will give you feedback.
So again, it's not just about
earning the certification,
it's also about learning as
you're doing and building
these projects.
And well, that's it.
That's what we had
to talk about today.
Thank you for
attending the talk.
We hope you're excited about
Google Developer Certification.
To find out more, go to our
site, read about the program,
and sign up.
You can also get
in touch with us.
We're going to be
here throughout I/O.
And you can Tweet at us.
Thanks again, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]